I found re now I've got her she's an
amazing designer so I know that we're
gonna make the dress my dreams he was
with Bachelor winner Lauren Burnham and
designer Hayley Paige at the JLM couture
show in New York there's probably gonna
be some glitter
we're re lion Dyke juniors fiance dished
on her wedding dress
Hayley is designing my wedding dress and
I just really vibe with her so well we
have very similar interests in style
I'm very girly she's very girly she
likes glitter I like glitter so it just
it works you know she understands what
I'm looking for the dress has been in
the works a few months ago and I've met
with her twice about it already I would
say it's a little bit of a princess vibe
but we're getting married in Maui and a
very rustic historical like jungle venue
so I'm kind of looking for something
elegant but also understated at the same
time the two will tie the knot at the
Haiku mill in January it's a historic
sugar mill and it was kind of taken over
by the jungle so it's gorgeous there's
vines everywhere greenery and I want to
find a dress that goes along with the
fairytale team as for Ari I know
already's got a really nice tux picked
out but I'll let him tell you guys about
that I'd love to have a tux that has you
know some grey but also some black not
just a traditional tux and so yeah just
something with a little bit extra Edie
joined the race car driver as he picked
out a suit for the big day I'm trying
not to really pry a lot because I know
that it's hard for her to keep his
secret and he revealed what kind of
dress he envisions his bride wearing as
they say I do she's so creative when it
comes to style and she's very very
fashion-forward so I'm expecting
something classic though because her
family so traditional I'm sure it's
gonna be beautiful
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]